OK, we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. This
voicemail is a textbook example of straw man.
OK.
Take a listen to what this caller says in
response to my recent story about coronavirus.
Take a listen.
Twice a day here calling for Fort Lauderdale,
Florida, watching your show, The David Pakman
Show.
Right.
You left out a lot of information.
A lot of it is not pragmatic or realistic
at all.
OK.
Twenty thousand people are not dying every
day.
The fourth that you're looking at are investigating
by people who have a vested interest of giving
you false information.
So remember, what the caller says is 20000
people are not dying every day.
Let's continue.
You're using their false information incorrectly.
It's just shameful.
I live down here.
I go back and forth to the beach every day.
Right.
We're having a great time.
They're enjoying their life.
There is no sirens on a daily basis letting
us know that people are dying at a massive,
aggressive rate.
OK.
You want to talk with me and contact me?
I can give you facts and proof and video feeds,
show you what's actually going on, regardless
of somebody who has some money in fingers
place into an investment of marketing.
The wrong idea that you seem to support.
Right.
So they say, David, you're wrong, 20000 people
aren't dying.
Yeah.
I never said 20000 people are dying.
I said 20000 or 25000 cases are being found
each day in the United States.
And that's true.
So this is what's called a strawman, arguing
against an argument I never made.
David, you're wrong that 20000 people are
dying.
Never said 20000 people are dying.
Says there is no sirens in Florida letting
us know people are dying.
I never said there were sirens in Florida
letting us know people were dying.
What I'm saying is we have data available.
If anything, the data is understating the
severity of the problem.
So guys do not make strawman arguments.
It looks bad.
It's not good.
Argue against what I say rather than what
you claim that I said.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Become a member to get instant access at join
Pacman dot com.
We will talk about an incredible story from
a hair salon about masks and corona virus.
And so, so much more.
I will see you on the bonus show if you are
a member.
If not, I'll see you tomorrow.